se han reunido en los márgenes de la
Cumbre del g20 en Bali para intentar
rebajar la tensión desde que vayden
alcanzó la Casa Blanca ha mantenido
conversaciones en cinco ocasiones por
videoconferencia Pero esto ha sido su
primera reunión en persona
principalmente porque la pandemia ha
mantenido así en China durante casi tres
años lo mejor que se puede decir es que
continúan los conductos de comunicación
abiertos a diferencia de lo que había
ocurrido en los últimos años de Donald
Trump Más allá de ahí no hay ningún
indicio para el optimismo esas charlas
solían servir antes para mantener la paz
durante meses o al menos semanas en la
última sin embargo apenas fueron unos
días son los que tardó la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes Nancy pelosi
en aterrizar en taipei Y es que la isla
Sigue estando en el centro del conflicto
Washington asegura que no ha cambiado su
política pero Es evidente que sí que lo
ha hecho cada vez frecuentes las ventas
de armas y las visitas de representantes
a la isla biden está dinamitando el
principio de ambigüedad estratégica que
había apuntalado la paz durante cuatro
décadas y cada vez hay más voces en
Washington que piden jubilar el
principio de una sola china
taipei es sagrado para china porque
alude a su soberanía territorial Y no
habrá relaciones bilaterales amistosas
mientras Washington persevere con su
política además esta reunión viene
precedida del intento de Estados Unidos
de estrangular la industria China de
semiconductores y Microchips con
sanciones es por todo ello que los
expertos no esperan que después de esta
reunión se recupere una sintonía
duradera